OBI WAN: The force
is what gives a Jedi his power.
It's an energy field created by
all living things.
It surrounds us and penetrates us.
It binds the galaxy together.
MACE WINDU:
You refer to the prophecy of the one
who will balance to the force.
You believe it's this boy?
OBI WAN: Before the dark times,
a young Jedi named Darth Vader,
who was a pupil of mine
until he turned to evil.
Vader was seduced by the dark side
of the force.
Anakin! You were the chosen one!
(LIGHT SABERS CLASHING)
(HEART BEATING)
(MECHANICAL BREATHING)
PALPATINE: Once more
the Sith will rule the galaxy.
(LIGHT SABER BUZZING)
(LIGHT SABERS BUZZING)
DODONNA: A precise hit will start
a chain reaction which should
destroy the station.
Then man your ships
and may the force be with you.
We will then crush the rebellion
with one swift stroke.
HAN SOLO: Chewy, get us out of here!
OBI WAN: Use the force, Luke.
VADER: I have you now.
OBI WAN: You must learn the ways
of the force.
ANAKIN: I’m not afraid.
OBI WAN: You will be. You will be.
One thing remains.
You must confront Vader.
VADER: You don't know the power
of the dark side.
(LIGHT SABER BUZZING)
If you will not fight,
then you will meet your destiny.
I am a Jedi...like my father before me.
Ben!
(LIGHT SABERS CLASHING)
OBI WAN: That boy is our last hope.
YODA: No. There is another.